les russes l'ont adopté depuis plusieurs
semaines les chinois également et
plusieurs pays européens ont tous
découvert récemment les avantages des
tests de détection de l'aco vide
basé sur la salif ce qu'on veut tester
grâce à cette technique l'ensemble du
personnel des étudiants une fois par
semaine ça représente trente mille
personnes par semaine à tester c'est
maintenant au tour des américains grâce
aux tests efficaces 5 et plus coûteux
mise au point par l'université de yale
amour université yale offre gratuitement
la recette de son nouveau produit à qui
veut bien l'utiliser au québec des
chercheurs ont déjà commencé à l'évaluer
première constatation pour l'usager
c'est pas mal plus agréable la
différence c'est qu'au lieu d'utiliser
un écouvillon on va les placer dans le
fond d'une on voudrait simplement à
requérir de la salive cachée d'un
individu ce genre de test exige
également moins de matériel et de
manipulation en laboratoire et moins de
personnel médical sur le terrain et
avoir des possibilités comme
travailleurs de la santé qui se déplace
sur un lieu où on veut faire un
dépistage à grande échelle par exemple
du travail ou une école où est-ce qu'on
pourrait être simplement demandent aux
gens sur place de faire leur clairement
avec supervision le texte devrait
conduire la majorité des clientèles à
l'exception peut-être des jeunes enfants
et de certains patients ch et celle des
pour certaines personnes qui ont des
problèmes quand il tirait des
difficultés de compréhension où ils
n'ont pas beaucoup de salive dans la
bouche à cause de certains médicaments
qu'ils prennent c'est peut-être pas une
bonne population questionner à la sortie
d'un centre de prélèvement la réponse
des principaux intéressés étaient
unanimes
j'aimerais bien ça je préférais la
salive c'est mieux parce qu'avec
né là c'est vraiment dur s'il votait
satisfait les critères de la santé
publique
il pourrait être disponible dès cet
automne ici norma grondin radio canada
montréal